cast discrimination exists in countries
and cultures around the world
in California activists mostly of South
Asian descent are fighting to stop it
cast is you know a severe form of
discrimination that impacts over 5.7
million South Asian Americans and
according to our data at equality Labs
we have found one in Four cast oppressed
people face physical and verbal assault
prempariar is a Nepalese Hindu immigrant
and a dollar among the lowest category
in the caste system
he came to the U.S after family members
were severely beaten by dominant caste
neighbors over a minor Financial dispute
to his surprise he found discrimination
in his adopted country there were like
some Nepali co-workers also
and they refused to share that shared
housing with me because I belonged to
cast oppressed Community I was like
almost I was homeless California state
Senator Aisha wahab hears stories of
cast discrimination from her
constituents many of them are unable to
advance in their careers even with the
technical knowledge and the education in
that particular field because they are
being discriminated one way or another
with a commitment to love respect and
Humanity that I have introduced SB 403
to End cast discrimination wahab has
introduced legislation making it clear
past discrimination is illegal like
other types of discrimination under
state law the individual's feeling that
they are discriminated against would
still have to have proof that
discrimination has taken place based on
their caste just the way that
discrimination based on race or gender
or age has to be proven one of the core
complaints we've heard from cast
oppressed peoples is that when they
report it companies are not taking
action to to fulfill their obligations
under civil and laborer laws opponents
of the bill say it stigmatizes Believers
in the Hindu faith and could lead to
racial profiling Hinduism has been
reduced here in a lot of public
perception and even in the textbooks to
a cast cows and Curry
phenomena and so this just perpetuates
those stereotypes and particularly
around Hinduism supporters say the bill
isn't about Hindu beliefs
it has nothing to do religion this is
completely social justice issue this is
human rights issue this is civil rights
issue supporters say if the bill passes
it will be an example for the rest of
the U.S and the world Rob Reynolds Al
Jazeera Oakland California